今天我們要聊一個很有意思的案例，一家餐廳，曾經在市場上掙扎，但它沒有像很多公司那樣去追逐最新的科技，反而做了件出乎意料的事。
怎麼說？現在不是大家都在聊 AI 嗎？很多餐飲業也想著怎麼用 AI 點餐、送餐。它不追 AI，那它做了什麼？難道是回到手寫菜單嗎？
當然不是手寫菜單那麼誇張啦。它回歸的是「基本功」。這家是 Chili’s，他們的母公司是 Brinker International。他們資訊長 Chris Caldwell 說，他們「不全心投入」AI。
「不全心投入」？這句話聽起來很有保留。現在大家都在搶 AI 的風口，他怎麼會這麼保守？這模式撐得久嗎？
其實這正是它厲害的地方。因為這個策略，Chili’s 的股價在四年內飆漲了 500%。銀行美洲的資深餐廳分析師 Sara Senatore 說，Chili’s 的轉型「簡直不可思議」。
股價漲 500%？這數字可不是開玩笑的。那他們具體做了什麼「基本功」？總不能光靠 Wi-Fi 升級就漲這麼多吧？
欸，Wi-Fi 升級還真是其中一個重點。Caldwell 在 2024 年 2 月剛到 Chili’s 的時候，發現很多基本設施都落後了。網路很差、點餐軟體很複雜，這些都影響員工效率和顧客體驗。
糟糕的 Wi-Fi？這很常見啊，但很少人會把這個當作解決公司困境的關鍵吧？一般人可能會覺得，要解決這種大問題，應該是直接導入最新科技來「彎道超車」才對。
是啊，這就是出乎意料的地方。他們用了兩年時間，升級了 1,200 家分店的 Wi-Fi，還重新談判了 Comcast 的合約，甚至加了蜂巢式網路備援。
重新談判合約、加備援線路，這些聽起來都是很「底層」的工作。而且，他們怎麼知道是這些「基礎問題」在拖後腿，而不是其他更複雜的原因？
Caldwell 提到，是這些基本問題在拖累員工。你想想，如果服務生用的平板電池續航力不足，點餐軟體又難用，Wi-Fi 又不穩，他們能提供好的服務嗎？
嗯，這倒是。員工使用起來不順手，客人等候時間變長，自然會影響用餐體驗。不過，除了 Wi-Fi，還有沒有其他更直接的「基本功」？
當然有。Caldwell 也砍掉了一些「華而不實」的計畫，像機器人服務生。他認為，如果機器人會妨礙客人體驗，那就該淘汰。
機器人服務生？現在很多餐廳都拿這個當賣點欸！他居然把它砍掉？那這樣聽起來，他似乎是在重新定義「什麼才是重要的」。
對，他把每項技術都導向一個目的：提升餐飲服務和用餐氛圍。他還買了 1,200 台新筆電給店經理，一台一台發下去，因為以前經理們只能用跟後台系統綁在一起的舊電腦。
這點我是信了，經理有一台自己的筆電，工作效率肯定差很多。那服務生呢？總不能還用舊平板吧？
沒錯，他們也採購了 23,000 台新 iPad 給員工用，取代那些電池不耐用、撐不完一整班的舊平板。這些投資讓 Chili’s 連續 20 季的同店銷售額都呈現成長。
20 季！那幾乎是五年了。這數字真的讓人不得不信服。這表示他們的「基本功」策略，效果不僅持久，而且實實在在反映在營收上。
沒錯。所以你說，如果是創業者或主管，能從這裡學到什麼？我覺得就是「專注」。不要老想著追新潮，而是想想顧客最在乎什麼？員工最需要什麼？
我猜啦，很多時候我們都會被市場上的「新概念」沖昏頭，覺得不跟上就會被淘汰。但其實最基本的服務體驗如果沒有做好，再多花俏的技術也沒用。
完全同意。那如果是一般上班族呢？這個概念可以怎麼應用到工作上？
我覺得就是把自己的「核心職能」先鞏固好。像是，做簡報有沒有做好資料查核？回覆信件有沒有條理清楚？這些基本功，可能比學一個新的軟體更重要。
沒錯，搞清楚自己工作中最影響效率、最容易出錯的「小地方」在哪裡，先把它們補起來，可能比一味追求高大上的技能更有效果。
好像也提醒了我們，有時候慢下來，把根基打穩，反而能走得更遠、更穩。
對，今天這個案例真的很值得大家思考一下，我們是不是也把太多精力放在「追新」，卻忽略了那些最簡單、卻也最核心的事情。